wir wollen uns nun die lage von einem
mann einschätzen lassen der gerade ein
sehr gefragter gesprächspartner ist wir
wollen jetzt sprechen mit dem ehemaligen
spd chef vizekanzler und jetzigen
vorsitzenden der atlantik brücke und
zugeschaltet sie hat sigmar gabriel
guten morgen herr gabriel morgen wir
alle sind im grunde noch in der
verarbeitungs phase dieser schrecklichen
ereignisse die noch in vollem gange sind
und vor allem die sicherheits ordnung
europas verändern
vielleicht auch noch länger was erwarten
sie
na ja leider das was eben gerade im
letzten beitrag gesagt wurde ich bin
auch relativ sicher dass das ziel ist
regime change in tier zu machen um das
land durch eine marionettenregierung
dann unter die kontrolle zu bekommen ob
das gelingt wird man auch sehen ich
meine das hat der beitrag ja auch
deutlich gemacht es gibt in der ukraine
nicht zuletzt durch den seit 2014
existierenden krieg im osten eine
massive
antirussische stimmung und die
bereitschaft auch zu kämpfen was man
auch zu verfolgen können dass es hohe
verluste gibt also man muss sehen aber
leider ist das in der tat das ziel herr
gabriel die nato kann ziemlich gering
ist das mittel das eigentliche ziel ist
russland zurück zu bringen in eine
großmacht position dass über die
schicksal ganz europas entscheiden
können dass es sein eigentliches ziel
die nato kann bzw will nicht wirklich
helfen militärische abschreckung wurde
zumindest bei uns aus
unterschiedlichsten gründen
vernachlässigt ob sanktionen
mittelfristig helfen fragezeichen
russland ist ja der ukraine militärisch
haushoch überlegen gibt es noch eine
chance für das land für eine souveräne
ukraine oder ist das jetzt vorbei
ich glaube dass jedenfalls auf kurze
sicht ist so sein wird dass gegen diese
massiven gewaltakt mann kommen was
machen kann ich meine ich sage ihnen mal
ganz offen ich höre das immer so mit
einem kritischen unterton dass die nato
nichts macht wollen wir wirklich in
einen nuklearkrieg mit russland
eintauchen das wäre nämlich die
konsequenz wenn die nato eingreifen
würde ich glaube dass wir nicht mal die
ukraine das wäre würde europa zu minute
bild machen
dann jedenfalls wird es nicht mehr geben
was am ende doch steht ich habe ein
bisschen deshalb optimismus was die
mittlere sicht angeht wir haben als
westen schon mal gezeigt dass wir ein
solches regime das anders geartet war
aber das jedenfalls den westen bedroht
hat niederringen konnten
zugegebenermaßen haben wir dafür relativ
lange gebraucht aber das wichtigste was
jetzt was wir jetzt brauchen ist
einigkeit denn hat der langen strecke
wird russland ist schwer haben gegen die
westlichen sanktionen anzukommen aus
chinesischer sicht ist russland
zweitklassig ich glaube dass das das
einzige wirkliche mittel hat aber es
muss auch hart sein und ist vor allem
durch halten putin testet unsere
durchhaltefähigkeit da ist meine größte
sorge dass wir nach einer weile wenn wir
merken solche sanktionen treffen auch
uns selber dass wir dann schwach werden
können das müssen wir verhindern ich
kann das nachvollziehen was sie gesagt
haben gleichzeitig sieht man ukraine im
land die verzweifelt sind die flehen um
hilfe und das richtung westen und man
kann irgendwie nichts machen das muss
man vermutlich jetzt ertragen wenn man
das so hart formuliert
die ehemalige verteidigungsminister in
annegret kramp karrenbauer hat gestern
etwas getwittert und das hat viele
aufgewühlt ich sie so wütend weil wir
historisch versagt hätten wir haben nach
georgien krim donbass nichts vorbereitet
was putin wirklich abgeschreckt hätte
können sie dem etwas abgewinnen
sie müssten höchstens vorkam war fragen
was sie denn mein das reh hätten tun
können nochmal militärische abschreckung
für das gebiet der nato gibt es ich
glaube dass die relative sicherheit der
drei baltischen staaten das haben auch
die politiker dort gesagt natürlich
daher kommt dass die mitglieder der nato
sind auch putin wird sich nicht wagen
auch wenn er jetzt derzeit ja große
sprüche macht die nato anzugreifen weil
auch er den nuklearkrieg fürchten muss
aber das sozusagen das hat die nato ja
getan wenn programm kann meint hätten
mehr tun müssen da gibt es ja nur ein
antwort dann hätten wir 2008 die ukraine
und georgien in die nato aufnehmen
damals gab es sorgen dass das erst recht
ein angriff russlands provozieren würde
ich glaube es gibt ein bisschen so wenn
man vom rathaus kommt ist man immer
schlauer als vorher
wir haben lange lange zeit gehofft dass
man mit russland auf der ebene von
verhandlungen ergebnisse erzielen kann
und das ist am ende von russland
zerstört worden ich kann auch sagen mal
den riverboat die in den ich jetzt
erlebe und den wir damals erlebt haben
in den winzer verhandlungen dann kriege
ich nicht in eine person also irgendwie
etwas muss auch russland passiert sein
ich glaube großen sehen eine große
chance sich zurück zur europäischen
großmacht zu bringen weil amerika
schwach ist weil europa zerstritten
erscheint weil wir weil er unsere
schwächen kennt bei energiepreisen die
wirtschaftliche schwäche in teilen
europas das stellt die sozusagen die
gespaltene situation in europa zwischen
ost und west ich glaube dass es jetzt
eine situation wo er den eindruck
vermittelt jetzt kann ich sozusagen
zurück zur imperialer größe und die
werden nichts machen können und wenn es
um militär geht ich glaube wir können
und müssen die bundeswehr besser machen
und müssen auch die nato besser machen
aber wenn man ehrlich ist selbst die
beste nato die beste bundeswehr würde in
der jetzigen situation nicht russland
angreifen
sondern wir wären in der gleichen lage
wie vorher wir wären nur etwas sicherer
vor ihm in den nato mitgliedsstaaten was
ja auch schon eine menge ist es bleiben
uns in der aktuellen situation zwei
möglichkeiten sanktionen und
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine damit
sie sich selber verteidigen kann das
sind die beiden möglichkeiten die wir
derzeit haben und dafür sorgen dass wir
durchhalten dass wir uns untereinander
in europa helfen dass wir die schwachen
staaten nicht alleine lassen aber sonst
angst haben müssen dass sie aus den
sanktionen aussprechen dass wir unsere
bürgerinnen und bürger führten den weg
weisen schützen das können wir alles tun
also mehr als helme für die ukraine ich
bedanke mich für die zeit die sich
genommen haben das war der vorsitzende
der atlantik brücke und ehemalige
bundeswirtschaftsminister und
vizekanzler sigmar gabriel dankeschön